look human beings we can't help
ourselves but compare ourselves to
others and
comparison is is the deadliest thing we
can do to ourselves because we will
always come up short i mean it'll all it
does is exaggerate all of our
insecurities
it's okay to enjoy other people's
success but you let them live their
lives and you live your life oh and by
the way they're curating their social
media that's not really their life
um and so you're making decisions based
on how you feel based on their curated
things i know i've talked to so many
millennials i know somebody who's out of
work really depressed and yet she goes
and does all these things so she has the
appearance of this amazing successful
life
and and so you met now she may be making
those decisions based on what her
friends oh who knows what sort of weird
twisted exaggerated you know circle of
of of depression this is forming
so go back to the rules of the infinite
game your friends are there to admire
your friends are there to say god that
i'm so happy for them what are they
doing that i can learn from i'll give
you an example so
we're all so we can all fall into this
trap so you know in my business
uh
authors and speakers and folks like us
we're all comparing ourselves to each
other and sometimes it can get silly and
competitive and there was you know
sometimes i go on amazon and check the
rankings of my books to see that there's
that i still have a job
and and now and then there was this one
author
who i hated for no reason
he's very smart his work's incredibly
good he's incredibly well respected i
respect him but i hate him
and i would check the rankings of his
books
and when i was ahead i'd be like yes
and when he was ahead of like
right it would drive me crazy i had this
weird abstract competition
same thing right social media happened
to be amazon rankings right
and i would check in all the time i'd
always check in mine his mind his nobody
else just mine and his
anyway we were uh i was at an event and
we were interviewed together on the same
stage
and the interviewer decided to let us in
introduce each other
so i went first i had to introduce him
and this is what i said i looked at him
and i said uh you make me very insecure
i said uh because all of your strengths
are all of my weaknesses
and every time i see you do well it just
reminds me what i'm bad at
that's how i opened up
he
he turned to me and he said funny i feel
the same way about you
and now we love each other
because i realized
that
he's really good at what i'm bad at so
by me getting to know him and really
learning to love him i'm realizing i'm
getting better at those things
and i'm taking more pride in the things
that i'm good at rather thinking rather
than thinking i have to be good at
everything he's good at
right so that that it's it's healthy to
grow our own strengths and rather than
be intimidated by the strengths of
others